again we have to break down all of the
fashion hits and misses from the Golden
Globes last night so we have our fashion
expert back with us today
[Music]
Frank Marino is joining us to talk all
things Sparkle Glitz glamor from last
night's silver carpet welcome back hey
baby I'd love to be here he says I live
for that open
it it really is uh it was a great night
I thought on the side I agree I agree I
I had an equal amount of outfits I just
love that were over the top and amazing
and I did have an equal amount of ones
that really I don't think made the cuts
it was really a 50 50. well let's let's
kick things off and talk about some of
your best stress picks because I was
really I was watching last night
thinking I'm wondering what Frank is
gonna like so who who was one of the
best dressed for you well uh one of the
best dressed for well we'll start with
the men uh yeah I don't know if you saw
Austin Butler but he did Elvis yeah and
did it amazing he's in Gucci and what I
like about the award shows is when you
stay traditional I I don't like when
they go wild and they add pink this and
green that I just thought he'd look
really classy and this is a big moment
for him and I thought he looked what a
clean look and definitely uh made Gucci
proud on that one I agree that's a great
pick okay let's talk about some of the
dresses that we saw and uh oh man Quinta
Brunson I gotta tell you I wanted to rob
that dress and use it in my show I
thought she looked fantastic and carried
it well a lot of times when you have a
big dress like that it wears you but she
wore it great obviously a big winner
from Abbott Elementary and that it
seemed
is
Ruckus too much is just enough with the
theme for last night and I loved it all
right from uh Pam and Tommy Lily James
was one of your best pay yes what do you
think let's see I don't even remember
what she was wearing that was the best
for me the whole night it was just it
was age-appropriate it wasn't matronly
it um just had sexiness in the right
spots it wasn't over the top I really
think she was the best best of the whole
night and what a color on that one
someone that I think you and I both love
Jean Smart yes she was on your list she
was wearing Tadashi last night which is
a designer that I actually started with
40 years ago just to say how long
they're around but what I love about
Jean is again age appropriate she didn't
try to look 25 years old you know and
she looked just very classy in the in
the tuxedo Vibe of the velvet gown and
uh if you haven't seen hacks you have to
see hacks because they stole my life did
you see it me and Joan Rivers had a
child it would be Jean Smart and hacks I
want to talk a little little bit about
my best picks and see what you think
Jenna Ortega and Gucci I thought this
was an interesting take a great nude
color what did you think of that I
thought it was good for someone her age
yes I agree and I I love her character
Wednesday and a lot of times when you
see her on these award shows she's
looking a little more Gothic I loved it
last night she went just traditional and
I thought she looked gorgeous also
Michelle yo I had her in Armani um she
looked spectacular in that navy color
and then Anna De armas she was wearing
Nicholas chess care and that I thought
was absolutely great let's talk about
the worst dress okay who did you not
love I guess we got to start with uh
Jamie Lee Curtis yeah you know I know
she's known for the Halloween sequels
and all that kind of stuff but she
didn't have to come as Dracula I didn't
understand why she hit the last minute
decided to take the dining room table
okay and then another one which I
actually liked you did not like Michelle
Williams I am a drag queen saying this
there was too many Ruffles you know when
you're supposed to turn around the first
thing you see take it off yeah I think
she added another one on okay so it it
just didn't balance out for me it was
just short long short yeah I didn't like
it well and one that you and I both
agreed on and my worst stress also this
I gotta tell you if she wasn't beautiful
if she wasn't Heidi Klum I would let her
get away with it but you're Heidi Klum
and you look I'm sorry she looked like a
hooker oh my goodness yeah
mostly the people that dress like that
are working outside of the building but
somehow she got in but I love you Heidi
I just don't love your choice for less
it was a questionable choice and I have
to agree with you thank you for your
fashion expertise Frank let's talk a
little bit about what you've got going
on well for the first time in 40 years I
don't have a steady show to go to every
night oh my goodness but we are doing
these brunches the drag queen brunches
at DW Bistro which have just taken off
we started with one now it's up to two
Presidents Day weekend the 19th of
February we'll have an 11 o'clock and a
one o'clock show they will sell out I
get calls the day before all my friends
call and say could you get me in I won't
be able to so I'm telling you a month in
advance as not a ploy we will sell out
come see us it's going to be an amazing
show we are so glad that you're still
giving us your expertise and we love
that you're still performing here in
town thank you so much thank you so good
to see you Ted let's send